Michael Flynn's Trump Russian
connections are insane in addition to
recently learning that disgraced former
Trump national security adviser Michael
Flynn was a foreign agent lobbying on
behalf of Turkey we have also now
learned that Michael Flynn was paid by
Russia's top cybersecurity firm while he
still had a top-secret level security
clearance in the United States I've said
it before and I'll say it again you
can't write this stuff according to new
documents obtained and published by the
House Committee on Oversight and
Government Reform Mike Flynn was paid by
Kaspersky a Russian cybersecurity firm
and there are trumpets that are still
insisting nothing to see here Flynn was
unfairly railroaded but I was looking at
the timeline who can really look at this
honestly and believe that there's
nothing to see here let's start with the
beginning let's walk through it April of
2014 Flynn is fired as director of the
DoD's Defense Intelligence Agency :
Powell says Flynn was quote abusive with
staff didn't listen worked against
policy bad management etc he has been
and was right-wing nutty ever since
end quote October of 2014 while Flynn
still had a top-level security clearance
he founded an intelligence consulting
firm called Flynn Intel group and
started performing intelligence work for
foreign clients as we now know one of
those clients being turkey summer of
2015
Flynn starts to advise Donald Trump many
of us familiar with that aspect of the
story at this point
in late summer of 2015 August Flynn gets
$15,000 from Volga knepper Airlines for
giving a speech this is a Russian
airline that was removed from the UN's
list of approved vendors after a
corruption scandal involving an indicted
Russian UN nations official go to
October of 2015
Flynn gets another $15,000 speaking fee
from a Russian cybersecurity firm again
Kaspersky Labs whose head was later
charged with treason as I mentioned
earlier
today December of 2015 Flynn gets a
$45,000 payday for attending a dinner
celebrating Russian state-controlled
propaganda news network arty he sat
right next to Vladimir Putin at that
dinner from August to November of 2016
Flynn was paid five hundred and thirty
thousand dollars to help Turkish to help
the Turkish government investigate a
coup this revelation came to light in
the last ten days of or so and in August
of 2016
Flynn started showing up at the
classified Intel briefings with Trump
again remember he was a registered
foreign agent at this point November 8th
of 2016
Flynn writes an op-ed in the hill called
our ally Turkey is in crisis and needs
our support
of course that didn't disclose that Mike
Flynn was being paid to help lobby on
Turkey's behalf November of 2016
Flynn meets with the Austrian extreme
right-wing party leader who signed a
cooperation agreement with Putin the
next month the Trump team denies that
the meeting occurred of course we now
know that it occurred cut to
inauguration day Flynn becomes national
security adviser to President Donald
Trump just a month later in February
Flynn leaves his office after it's
uncovered that he lied about his
communications with Russia during the
election and most recently in March of
2017
Flynn filed papers acknowledging that he
worked as a foreign agent in 2016
representing the interests of the
Turkish government in a dispute with the
United States there are people who would
look at this Pat and say David that's
not only sketchy we need to investigate
whether this man is a bonafide traitor
not everybody would say that but what is
not deniable at this point is that this
is more than mere details on the fringes
and also that this is only one of the
people involved with Trump that has this
type of thing in his past we've got
former Trump campaign manager Paul
Manafort remember he resigned in shame
when it surfaced that he was being
looked at for potentially receiving
illegal payments for Russian
Altman he now is reportedly wanted for
questioning in a Ukrainian corruption
case it's bad who can look at this
objectively and say nothing to see here
folks and notice that these are people
in Trump's inner circle it's not like
it's the deputy chairman of some RNC
state organization somewhere these are
the people that have is ear 24 hours a
day literally and I guess if there's a
good thing that comes out of this it's
that in the case of Michael Flynn
resigning the new National Security
Advisor is HR McMaster who's arguably an
actual good person for that role
effective all human beings seemingly not
tied to Russia in countless sketchy and
and disturbing ways so yeah if there is
a silver lining it's that what will
happen with Jeff Sessions we don't know
what will happen ultimately with Paul
Manafort we don't know it's bad it's
really bad send me your thoughts on
Twitter I'm on Twitter at D Pakman the
show is on Twitter at David Pakman show
we'll take a break and be back we've got
a hell of a program for you today
today's program is made possible in part
by movement watch's movement watches and
by the way I'm wearing my relatively new
movement watch this is the black face
with the blue hands which I really
really like movement watches was started
by basically two broke college guys in a
dorm room who would go to department
stores they'd see watches that they
liked and they'd be four to five hundred
dollars too expensive so instead they
cut out the middlemen and sell directly
on their website MVM T watches dot-com
and as a result watches start at just 95
bucks they've sold over 500,000 watches
at this point and people really like the
watches everywhere I go with both this
watch and the other one that that I have
from movement watches people immediately
look at it I can tell when I'm talking
people start looking at the watch and
whatever I'm saying the next thing they
say is where did you get that watch
that's really cool and you can go to mV
mt watches calm slash Pakman to get 15%
off your movement watch today they make
great gifts you get free shipping as
well as free returns check out mV mt
watches dot-com / Pakman that is pH
ma n